For all the CEOs and founders who
are listening, on April 1st, we will
start accepting applications for the 2023
class of the Seed Transformation Program.
The 11 month intensive program
will start in January, and
it includes a combination of face to face
teaching, networking and virtual learning.
You'll have the opportunity to participate
in a cohort of 60 other like minded
entrepreneurs from across your region.
Founders and CEOs of companies
based in Sub-Saharan Africa and
South Asia, with annual revenue of at
least $300,000 are eligible to apply.
If you are a company,
you know may be interested,
please visit Stanford seed.co
forward/apply to learn more.
[MUSIC]
>> There is a Japanese saying that,
sometimes you have to jump through
a window, not knowing what's outside.
And the knowledge of exactly what
the problems are, is itself a constraint.
Every entrepreneur has to
wrestle with the unknown.
The most successful ones develop a skill
set to help them deal with the things that
they can't predict.
Therefore, I think that if I had
known too much about banking,
I may not have done it.
But in that sense I was
the professional banker.
I was just an MBA,
who just had that certain overconfidence,
that MBAs have,
that any problem can be analyzed.
Can be assessed as
a problem of management.
The strategy can emanate from it,
and you should be able to execute.
[MUSIC]
>> I'm Doris Tutor, and
welcome to season two of grit and
growth from Stanford seed
The show where Africa and
India's of trypot entrepreneurs,
share their trials and triumphs.
With insights from Stanford faculty and
global experts,
on how to tackle challenges and
grow your business.
[MUSIC]
You'd be hard-pressed to find a more
accomplished person than our guest today.
Esteemed businessman Hakeem, Bella-Osagie.
This show isn't long enough to list
Hakeem's, many accomplishments, but he has
been a driving force in the Nigerian
economy for the last three decades.
Across such disparate sectors as energy,
finance and telecoms.
He's a business leader,
a philanthropist, and an educator.
He's on the Council of Foreign Relations,
the International Advisory Council at
the Brookings Institute, and he's
a lecturer at Harvard Business School,
although we won't hold
that one against him.
He's also the new chair of
Stanford seeds board of directors.
Hakeem has a unique understanding of
the African entrepreneurial ecosystem and
the challenges it faces.
I sat down with Hakeem, to hear about his
perspectives on the Nigerian economy and
the rapid growth of FinTech startups.
His experience taking over a state
run bank in the late 90s, and
his vision for the modern business leader.
Here's Hakeem humble and
understated as always.
>> My name is Hakeem Belo-Osagie,
I am from Nigeria.
I went to University in England and
in the United States
>> That would be Oxford, Cambridge, and
Harvard.
In case you were wondering.
>> I then went back to Nigeria and
worked in the government of Nigeria for
many years in the president's office, and
then decided after maybe a decade that
I wanted to become an entrepreneur.
And I think I madly
overestimated my abilities.
And my first entrepreneurial venture
in finance was a complete failure,
the bulk of which was
entirely my own fault.
But it was a wonderful lesson.
And I was able to pick myself up,
and the second venture of
mine which was a securities
trading companies went very well.
Subsequent to that I staged the takeover
of a large government owned bank
that I realized after buying the bank
that it was if effectively bankrupt.
This is your this is United Bank
of Africa and you know the
>> United Bank for Africa.
>> I always get it wrong myself so,
let's just leave it at UBA [LAUGH]
>> Okay, United Bank Africa
[MUSIC]
We'll return to Hakeem's experience that
United Bank for Africa in just a moment.
But first, I wanted to hear Hakeem's
perspective on Nigeria as a whole.
What are its opportunities for
long term growth?
And what stands in the way?
[MUSIC]
>> I am cautiously optimistic about
the growth prospects of Nigeria.
I think that the fundamentals are as
follows, a large population and
a population that I would say,
is entrepreneurial,
I hesitate to use the word
as a matter of culture.
But so I simply say has historically
been entrepreneurial, and
that has had a very deep sense that money
is to be made is not embarrassed or
ashamed of that,
has a sense of initiative, and
does not feel dependent on government.
And therefore, that set of human
resources is a huge advantage for
any country as it intends to develop.
It does have an oil base,
which even during a time
of energy transition,
I think is important.
And therefore, if properly used,
gives you the capacity to build and
to fund an infrastructure,
which is very important for
the growth of any country or economy.
>> Can I jump in right there?
So, we all heard the term Dutch disease,
where the dominant commodity
sector pulls resources which more
efficiently might be allocated to some
other activity then, oil and gas,
as petroleum becomes a less important
part of the overall GDP of Nigeria.
Well, we see kind of a reverse of
the resource curse and see more and more
investment flowing into other productive
sectors, or is that already happened?
>> I don't think it's already happened.
I think that the initial movement away
from oil, will be recessionary for
Nigeria.
Because I think that Nigerians have
gotten very used to the sense that
there's a floor that a certain level
of oil earnings gives an economy and
I think we're going to have to we
will struggle to adapt to that.
But I do think that as that situation
persists, a certain determination,
a certain resolution will kick
in as we now in a sense have
our backs against the wall and
now know, that densify
our efforts to develop the economy
>> You mentioned this,
large population,
an entrepreneurial mindset and spirit.
I've also heard you say in another
interview that you're kind of tired of
the demographic dividend that
people keep talking about.
That having this very wide
flat demographic pyramid, yes,
it could be an asset, but
it could also be a liability.
Could you say a bit more worry about that?
>> Yes.
The thing is that all of the arguments for
why a country can be successful,
are the same arguments as to why
a country can be unsuccessful.
So, for example, a large market It
can simply be 100 million people
who have very little income,
very little spending power,
it can simply mean that you have
a problem of overpopulation,
you can't educate all the people
concerned on the one hand.
On the other hand, it can also mean
that you have a wonderful market
within which to test the products,
to perfect the products, and
then to form the basis of going into
exports, so you can go either way.
Now, what I think is going to
determine which way Nigeria goes is
really going to be
the quality of leadership.
And it's going to be
the quality of leadership,
not only at the business level,
but almost,
I would say, in some respects more
important at the political level.
Because I think that the political
level determines the framework which
allows business leadership either to excel
or it constrains business leadership.
And just to make an international
comparison, if we just look at two
countries in the early 60s, and
I'll use the Middle East as an example.
You look at the United Arab Emirates and
you look at Libya.
Both had 1 to 1.5 million
barrels a day of oil.
Both had populations that were not
largely educated in the early 60s.
In many respects, Libya was ahead
because it was in the Mediterranean,
and you'd have thought that with
proximity to Europe assisted it greatly.
But now when you look at it 50
years later, why has Abu Dhabi,
why has Dubai taken off from desert
towns that nobody thought were
going to be catapulted to where they are
right now, and where is Libya right now?
That really came down to
the quality of leadership.
>> So let's talk about that.
So good governance is a precondition for
broad based, robust,
persistent economic growth,
let's put it that way.
So what is the impetus, because we
all know why there's bad governance,
because there are certain interests
that are being protected.
And in a lot of economies, I've worked
in many, many countries in my life,
it's usually that very powerful vested
legacy interests are doing everything they
can to maintain their place and to prevent
new entrants to prevent competition.
And they do that through all sorts
of import duties, export licenses,
quotas, regulation that's
designed to reduce competition.
Where will the impetus for
good governance come?
Will it come from countries realizing
that they're all competing for
the same human and investment capital?
And that the winners will be the ones
that create a more stable, reliable,
predictable playing field?
>> I think it's going to come in two ways.
On the one hand, the crisis or
the difficulties the countries endure,
in many respects triggers
off a certain introspection.
And I'll just say that if you
look at countries like Japan,
the crisis of the Second World War.
Look at what happened to Europe, and
you can see the way in which it ushered in
years of enormous growth in the 1950s and
early 60s.
So I think crisis forces people and
forces nations to think again,
and to rethink their model.
So I think that that's
going to be one impetus.
And therefore I think that paradoxically,
the COVID situation, the energy
transition, is going to lead to a certain
amount of rethinking, that's one aspect.
The second thing which I'd like to point
out, which is usually not often pointed
out, it comes from what you've
said about vested interests.
I'd like to take a slightly
different angle on what you've said.
I think that there will always
be vested interests and
there will always be powerful groups
who take care of themselves, and
I'm not so
sure that's the crucial question.
I think the crucial question is, that
elite that is taking care of themselves,
what is their long-term vision for
themselves and for their countries?
Do they have a long-term vision in
which they still want to be on top but
they have the sense that they
have got to do enough for
the base of the population
to remain there?
And do they have a picture of themselves
as being the leaders of great countries?
And you can characterize several countries
who are very much like that, all right?
Or is their vision very extractive?
They don't really care what
happens to everybody else.
>> They have three passports,
their money's in a bank somewhere else.
>> Absolutely, and so deep down
they don't really care, all right?
And they don't have a sense of patriotism.
And I see it very much in, for example,
I'll go back to the Middle East.
And I see very much that however well to
do I see some of the leading families in
the Middle East, it's still important
that Emirates does very well.
[MUSIC]
>> Hakeem has plenty of
experience with extractive elites
from the six years he ran
the United Bank for Africa.
This time at UBA gave him a deeper
understanding of these systemic challenges
that face African finance even now.
>> Now, I understand that when
you took the government's shares,
what you inherited was a bank
with far too many employees,
a high portfolio of non-performing loans,
and it was not very well managed.
That's a dumb-
>> And highly politicized.
>> So what business does a guy who never
ran a bank have jumping into that?
>> Interesting that you
asked that question.
There's a Japanese saying that
sometimes you have to jump through
a window not knowing what's outside.
And the knowledge of exactly what
the problems are is itself a constraint.
And therefore, I think that if I
had known too much about banking,
I may not have done it,
I may have said, this is just too much.
But in that sense, I wasn't professional
banker, I was just an MBA who just
had a certain overconfidence that MBAs
have that any problem can be analyzed.
Can be assessed as
a problem of management,
a strategy can emanate from it,
and you should be able to execute.
And that was my going in
approach to the matter.
>> Hakeem's story isn't just
about the problems he faced,
it's about how he solved them.
>> You've got to start shifting
who are the customer base.
How are the procedures improved upon.
How do people get into the culture
of marketing when they've really
been accustomed to people coming
in to see them as the banker.
They don't see the banking as
a service industry in a sense,
a lot of it has to do with the prestige
of people coming to you to borrow money.
>> So I love this point.
So, I want you to share with me a moment,
a critical inflection point,
where you needed the bank's leadership and
staff to adopt your cultural mindset
about what this bank should be.
Is this a matter of very
slow incremental change?
Was there an all hands meeting in-
>> No.
>> The conference hall where you said,
folks, this is who we are going to be?
>> No, I think there was never one,
there was several.
But the one that always hits me
the most is the time at which I kind
of laid out our situation,
our financial situation, and
why we're going to have to
do certain kinds of things.
I did it on a Thursday or Friday,
and on Monday the workers and
some of the management had taken over the
head office building and locked us out.
That was a pivotal moment for me.
[LAUGH]
>> Because they knew headcount cuts
were coming.
>> They knew cuts were coming and
they genuinely thought that I was
absolutely talking nonsense, okay?
Or in some cases they just could not take
change, human beings don't like change.
And maybe if I was one of them,
I would have reacted the same.
So that was the pivotal moment for me.
And it was then to just finally go and
sit down and.
Talk to a whole lot of them,
very hostile environment.
Mr. Belo-Osagie,
why do you hate people so much?
Why are you so mean?
Why are you so vicious?
Why do you like sacking people,
just because you're privileged?
And explaining that the path
we are taking is going to
lead us to the complete
collapse of the bank.
And they say, no,
it's never going to happen.
Climate change, never going to happen.
And you're trying to break it down to them
and say, this is where we're going to go.
All right,
I will go the way you're going, but
these are the signs that
you're going to see.
And as you see those signs,
let's reconsider, all right?
And so
I think that one was a pivotal one for
me because my fear was,
I need to carry them along,
but will they realize it so
late that we've gone over the edge?
>> So, that's fascinating.
So it was your sense that some
meaningful proportion of the bank's
employees had no idea about its financial
troubles, or didn't fully understand.
>> They didn't fully understand.
>> Did that include managers,
senior people?
>> Yeah, managers in particular.
[LAUGH]
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> Did not understand the cash
position of this bank.
>> They didn't understand where it was
inevitably going to lead because previous
to that,
a lot of the accounts had been falsified.
So they were just declaring these profits,
but
effectively they were
eroding their capital.
And most of them were not aware of it.
For a lot of them, for example,
didn't realize that, look,
we are banking old customers
who are going nowhere.
There is a whole new group
of customers that we're
not banking who are going to be the
future, and we need to start banking them.
>> Managing a sometimes hostile workforce
taught Hakeem about the empathy
required to be an effective leader.
>> So you needed to help them
understand that this was a crisis.
>> Yes.
>> And
then you needed to help
them have a vision-
>> Yes,
>> Of a way out?
>> Yes, correct.
>> And
you committed to metrics along the way so
that people could see what
was actually happening?
>> Yes, now, there's another point though.
I also needed to understand
why they hated me, all right?
I didn't understand it until that event,
until this lady,
I remember she came up to me and
she just said to me, Mr. Belo-Osagie,
I'm going to give you a chance because
you said something of the speech.
You said that, you don't like firing
people, and you told a story about
how you read a story to your daughter
before she went to bed at night.
because your daughter asks you, dad,
people in school keep saying that
your dad likes retrenching people,
what does retrench mean?
So the lady looks at me and said, the fact
that you could actually read to your
daughter at night means that
you can't be completely evil.
That's the exact word she used, okay?
And I think that it suddenly struck me
that I had to also think about
how I was appearing to them.
And then I had to realize that a lot
of the people who came in to change
the bank were people like me.
And therefore there were not many people
who were like the people who were
trying to change, all right?
And therefore there was
a cultural conflict as well.
And I needed to now start bringing
other kinds of people to work with me,
who were closer to the people I
was trying to change, all right?
Because they could better sell
what we were trying to do.
So, for example, if you're running
a company in which they're all high school
educated folks, and
that's how banks were in those days, and
you're arriving with a group of
trendy investment banking types,
all MBAs,
you're obviously setting yourself.
[LAUGH] But I didn't see that at the time.
But that was a critical event in which
I saw I needed to change them and
I saw how I needed to change myself.
[MUSIC]
>> You've been involved as an investor, as
a mentor, or somehow tangentially involved
in some of the biggest tech
startups on the continent.
And I was going to ask you,
there seems to be a lot of frothy
excitement about health tech,
EdTech, MedTech, FinTech,
and a lot of new capital
flowing into these sectors.
Does the market justify this
level of excitement and energy?
And is there enough for everyone to grow?
And just in the Nigerian market,
let's go to the continent in a second.
>> All right, the first thing I'll
say to you is that there's really
nothing unusual about the excitement.
There was excitement about the banking
industry in Nigeria at one time, and
we had 100 banks at one time.
There was an excitement at one point about
the oil and gas industry, and we had
about 100 groups who were all setting
up their Mickey Mouse oil companies.
And in a sense, that is probably,
in my view, a good thing.
Because what it does mean is that
rather than a government agency,
all right, only allow three or
four powerfully connected groups
to dominate an area,
you have a huge amount of competition.
And then inevitably,
there's going to be a shakeout.
Some are going to survive and
be very strong and
very profitable and
many others will just go by the wayside.
Now, in the early years,
everybody will be doing well.
But inevitably what then
happens is that some can no
longer continue to lose the money
that they're losing and
the special breaks are no longer there and
they will fall by the wayside.
And I've seen it, the oil and gas
industry, we saw it in banking in Nigeria,
and we're going to see
the same thing in tech.
And out of this, I think a couple
of very strong groups will emerge,
which have a combination of the basic
model is very good, it's a good model.
The second element of it is that they
have had to make that adaptation from
brilliant idea to effective management
that successfully scales and
handles that transition.
And not all groups can do that.
And then at the same time, it's also
got to maintain a good relationship and
understanding of the national
regulatory environment,
which in the sense,
forms the basis of competition.
[MUSIC]
>> That national regulatory environment
may be the biggest key to whether these
tech startups,
particularly in finance, can succeed.
>> I think that the FinTech companies,
they will go much farther
than people expect.
And that the only thing I think that will
restrain them is going to be regulation.
It's a regulatory environment
that thinks banks and
sees the protection of
the existing banks as number one.
>> I've heard you say in a previous
interview that for a lot of businesses
how you manage the government is 50 to
60% of your work in a place like Nigeria.
What does that mean?
>> That means that because
the government is such a critical
market player in the sense that
it's either buying services.
Where it is not buying services, it is
providing services on which you depend.
It is writing the rules of the game,
all right?
And it has such an overwhelming
power within the judicial system,
in which yes,
you can enforce your rights, but
the time taken to enforce your rights,
you may no longer exist as a company.
Now, if that mindset is accompanied My
mind set on the pot of the bureaucrats or
the political officials that we have
the right to exercise this power.
Then you find yourself having to work
to deal with that entity, all right?
The government.
Now, a lot of young people, of course,
have grown up in an environment in
which government was a bad thing.
The less government the better government,
there are children of the Reaganite and
the Thatcherite generation.
Now my generation is in that sense
different were from the LB Johnson,
the Kennedy and Vishnu.
It was a good thing.
What it does mean is that they've got to
move away from thinking of
the government as a hostile group.
But a government in some
identity in which you've got
to explain to them what you're doing.
They've got to understand the technology.
They've got to understand the ecosystem.
And many of them simply
don't understand it.
And when government officials
don't understand something,
their instinctive reaction is to say no.
>> Right, it's so much easier to say no,
it's much less risk.
I'm absolutely stunned at the number
of startups in this space and
all then sort of Neo banks and non banks
and all the things that they're providing.
Now I'm going to stipulate that there is a
role for regulation to protect consumers.
>> Absolutely.
>> Put yourself in the shoes of the
Nigerian regulator, I think it's NTIDA,
I don't know which agency.
But what are they doing to stay current
and to create a regulatory environment
that serves the function of regulation
without strangling the market?
>> What I think they need to do more of,
and
I won't say that they're
against the tech companies.
Because I've experienced this
kind of situation when we
first started a securities
trading company.
We had to spend a lot of time talking
to the banking supervision to say we're
not a bank.
>> We are not taking deposits.
>> We're not taking deposits.
And then to start encouraging them,
why don't you go visit other countries
that are say five years ahead of Nigeria,
so you can get a sense of
what the future is like.
And then you can then talk to other
regulators who have experienced this and
who have seen that it's not as
frightening as you think it is.
And then the next thing is that you've got
to let the regulator's know in a way that
is not condescending, okay?
That they need to understand the issues
and they've got to hire into the central
bank, a lot of people who are younger
than they are, who understand that.
I believe that participants in
the marketplace have to share with them.
Look, there's some funny things
that are going on, okay?
And we admit it.
All right, and these are the steps we will
take to ensure that it won't happen again.
So therefore, there's a set amount of
self regulation that needs to take place.
And sometimes you've also
got to call yourself out,
because that builds a certain
trust with regulator.
So he doesn't see it as us and them.
>> What about if the real force
behind the regulation is not visible?
That there are very powerful entrenched
interests actually turning the dials.
And I can think of examples where in
pacer tried to move, for example,
into South Africa and
the bank saw this mile away.
>> Yes.
>> And
said no way these guys [INAUDIBLE] much.
>> Absolutely.
>> We'll do what they're
doing when we're ready.
>> Yes.
>> This is high risk.
Trust us, we'll be there eventually.
How much of that sort of?
>> Yes.
>> Wizard of Oz behind the curtains
going on here?
>> Okay, yes,
now where the incumbent waves
the national flag they're their strongest.
So the M PESA one into
South Africa to me is expected,
the existing banks will wave
the national flag, wrap it round.
We're protecting our nation against these
foreigners who with these bizarre ideas.
Now, what will be interesting is how
they react to the South African M PESA.
All right, or a group of younger
techies inspired by an M PESA.
Maybe even funded by MPESA.
And that then poses the question or
says, look,
you the large incumbents who
grew up in the apartheid regime.
What have you done for
lending for the poor folks?
How have you been inclusive and
we think we are taking a shot at that.
And why should we be regulated
out of that competition?
Now that to me would be
an interesting challenge.
And that to me is some that may happen.
So I think that even within
incurs like Nigeria,
I think the biggest issue that a lot
of the public has about big banks,
is that it hasn't in a sense
benefited the wider population,
in the way in which Telecom's has.
So the Telecom's companies, it started
off, only the well to do headphones.
All right, but
today the poor have phones and
pricing has steadily dropped.
Not that we haven't had that same
inclusive aspect to banking.
[MUSIC]
>> Given Hakeem vantage point
on African finance, I wanted his
opinion on some of the questions that we
explored on Season One of Grit and Growth,
about FinTech and about the future
of debt for small businesses.
>> What will it take to make credit
affordable to SMEs that want
$100,000 capex loan in
the African continent?
Because if I have to say we have
1000 alumni from our program.
And these are typically, I mean about 30%
of them are tech or tech enabled, but
most of them are not on some kind of
hockey stick growth trajectory.
Or if equity was available to them,
they're actually not interested in
giving up ownership of their company.
What they want is reasonable, affordable
credit to grow and build their business.
And I don't care what country
you're in with a few exceptions.
The complaint is that it's just not there.
Banks are just not interested in business.
>> Let's look at it from the point of
views as to why don't the banks want
to go into that area?
I think that it comes down
to the following issues.
One is there's got to be enough data
that can predict who repays and
who doesn't repay.
So I think that the question of
what data is predictive, and
how can you accumulate it?
I think that's one,
in a very big important aspect.
Then I think the second
important aspect is what is
the technology that can allow
us to access these customers and
utilize this predictive data, in a manner
that drops the cost of doing so.
Because ultimately, if the cost
of acquiring a customer going for
the transaction and
making enough successful repayments,
that cost has to be less than the revenue
generated from giving the loan.
And ultimately, I think that's a question
of technology, data and how it is done.
And I think that as you begin to
crack that question, that problem,
you will then begin to
make progress there.
But I don't think that can be done in
the traditional manner in which we have
sought to do it till now.
>> Although Hakeem sees entrepreneurs
bringing real progress,
he also preaches patience
>> The thing I want
to point out is that as
always in lots of new ideas,
you will always have those companies
who they have the basic idea.
And they can speak to it.
And then you've got another set,
which is usually a subset,
who approach this thing with intense and
unrelenting rigor.
>> You mean on execution?
>> Yes.
>> In operation?
>> Yes, and there's always sometimes,
in some companies,
a desire to move very quickly.
because you have this sense
that you've got to move quickly
before your competitors and there's
money flowing in, investing in you.
And there's the danger
that you then launch and
you then grow before you have all of
these issues totally figured out.
>> Is that pressure coming from
the investors or from the founders?
>> In some cases, the investors.
And I think that part of that is
due to the fact that we still have,
and I would call it a US-imposed three
to five year cycle in investments, okay?
And I say US-imposed not because the US
government directed it, but because
the timing in the United States for a lot
of these things is three to five years.
And then you-
>> Strategic exit or something.
>> Exactly.
>> You get your money back out.
>> Exactly, now,
in my own experience as an entrepreneur,
three to five years,
I was still turning around.
I'd realized that I needed
to pivot a little bit here.
I realized that I'd got some hires wrong,
okay?
And I found it was really somewhere
between years five and seven, all right?
Or six, seven, eight,
that I now felt I was in my stride.
And then you started to get the truly
phenomenal or exponential growth.
And it had a solid base, all right?
So I do think that we need
a longer time horizon.
So there's got to be more
patience in the capital.
And also the founders
themselves needs to acknowledge
that they've got to do very diligent
work before they roll things out.
On the one hand, you've got that vision,
and I hate to use that word, but
you know what I mean.
But you've got to reduce that to
the series of steps that you need
to move from where you are to
where hopefully you want to go to.
And if I have a worry it's that,
I know lots of young folks who
they've got that big picture,
but the boring bit of this step and
this step and this step,
which is often mundane, tiring, and
exhausting, that is as crucial.
>> And as a founder,
you have to be more than just diligent.
You've gotta be able to trust yourself and
your process.
>> Courage is vital in
whatever you're doing.
You're really leading people down
a path in which you pretend you
can see the end of the tunnel as a leader,
but you can't really.
But you have a sense that this
is roughly where you need to go.
I often quote McNamara,
who talked about the fog of war.
And I deeply believe that there
is also a fog in business.
There is so much that you don't know.
And I think great leaders have the ability
to live with not knowing all the answers,
but being able to carry people along and
solve those issues as they come along.
And having the flexibility
to make those changes.
And having the sense of security
of saying to themselves,
don't know everything, but
I'll solve it as it comes along.
The founder has got to have
an appreciation of the complete array
of talents that he or she needs and
of bringing them together.
There'll be some folks who are
particularly good at solving the technical
problem.
There are one or two folks who their
forte is operations and just executing.
There are one or
two folks are going to be very good
at the fundraising element of it.
Constantly thinking about
the cash flow analysis,
warning that the spend is very high, and
don't think you have as much runway
as you think you have, all right?
So I think that all of these talents
really have to come together, and I think
a founder has to appreciate that it's
only a genius that is good in everything.
That's why I think the business history,
which all founders worldwide study,
has to let them know, that yes,
there was Bill Gates.
Yes, there was Steve Jobs.
But, without a doubt, there were two or
three other people who
worked with Bill Gates,
who you don't hear as much about, but
who were indispensable to the overall
success, and the same with Steve Jobs.
But the weight is one person gets
a disproportionate share of the limelight
and therefore it creates a misleading
sense of why you're successful
>> I love the mindset point,
because so many founders in
the early days are being called on
to solve problems that are way outside
their comfort zone and they have to do it.
>> Yes.
>> But they also have to
understand that a certain point,
that's going to slow the company down,
right?
We call it post-heroic leadership,
where you don't have to be
the hero of every story, right?
And for technical challenges for
which there is a solution,
you just maybe have to spend
some money to find it.
>> Yes.
>> That type of leadership can work.
But for what we call in the Stanford
program, adaptive challenges.
>> Yes.
>> Challenges to your strategy,
competitive landscape,
exogenous shocks,
that there without a team, you're lost.
And if the team thinks that you're
going to have all the answers,
they're not going to come up with any.
>> Absolutely, and
I think it also introduces and
confronts this issue of trust.
Trust in the sense that, here you are,
you're in a country in which there
are different ethnic groups,
different religious groups.
And you're going to have to work with
people, often that you don't know,
in a society in which it
is not heavily structured.
In a society in which there is not
as much rule of law elsewhere.
And therefore the need to work with
people that you trust becomes essential.
And oftentimes the problem of
the founder is that he has
difficulty in trusting other people.
Because he's heard so
many stories about how A trusted B and
B took off with the company.
[MUSIC]
>> Hakeem's views on leadership reflect
his broader views about the individual and
the collective, and
what truly makes a business successful.
[MUSIC]
>> You were a guest keynote speaker at
the Stanford Africa Business Forum earlier
this year.
And you made a comment that business
leaders in Africa are overrated.
>> [LAUGH] I really think that,
I think for two reasons.
One it's because just kind of
businessman in Africa, really have,
as his ultimate objective, only
the maximization of shareholder value.
We have the debate in
the United States all the time.
Part of me thinks in the United States
it's an easier question simply because
this is already a very wealthy society.
Now, in Africa, the imbalance of power,
the skewed nature of power is even worse.
So to me, one of the things that
worries me a lot is that we've
spoken a lot about how business
should be in the forefront,
the government should leave and
hand it over.
But we still haven't found how, for
example, the private sector, which is
supposed to be heroic, how does it deliver
Low cost medicine to the population.
How can it deliver infrastructure that
goes outside of the capital city and
of one or two other commercial centers?
How does it develop?
Low cost education health everybody.
We haven't.
>> But I think you've answered the
question you didn't want me to ask also,
which is that,
it's not that you have to abandon
the maximization of shareholder value.
>> Yeah.
>> It's that your success should matter to
someone other than you.
>> Yes.
>> That's when [CROSSTALK] we tried to
pick companies for the Seed Program.
>> Yes.
>> Of course we like social enterprises
that are commercially viable, but
the question I always ask is,
if this company grows 10x will it
matter to anyone other than the owners?
>> Yes.
>> Are they solving a problem that I care
about, that people there care about?
Are they solving a meaningful and
important problem?
>> But that problem is even more
acute in Africa and therefore,
more and more and more.
We have to measure how well we're doing,
not by how many people
on the Forbes cover,
not by how many billionaires Africa has,
but basically what has
happened to the bottom 40%.
Are we able to say,
as the Chinese can say, with many things
we don't like about the political system,
but they can say,
we over the last 40 years have lifted
x hundred million out of poverty?
And I think that business strategy,
business success has
got to be a strategy that
yes enables great companies,
allows people to make
certain effective and
enterprising people to
make good sums of money.
But it is also got to be a system
that lifts out of poverty
large proportions of
the overall population.
>> I think this is the most
compelling part of Hakeem's outlook.
That success on both the micro and macro
level is never about just one person,
it's about everybody.
It's reflected in how he leads his
views on regulators and his hopes for
the future of the continent.
It's a vision that we at
Stanford Seed share and
it's why he's such a good fit for us.
I'd like to thank Hakeem Belo-Osagie.
We're lucky to have him on the podcast and
as our board chair.
Hakeem's philosophy aligns so well with
what we're doing here at Stanford Seed.
And we're excited to work with him
to make our programs even better.
[MUSIC]
This has been grit and growth with
Stanford Graduate School of Business, and
I'm your host Darius Teter.
If you liked this episode,
leave us a review on your podcast app.
It really helps us to share the stories
of these incredible entrepreneurs with as
many people as possible.
To learn how Stanford Graduate School of
Business is partnering with entrepreneurs
throughout Africa and South Asia,
head over to the Stanford Seed website at
seed.stanford.edu/podcast.
[MUSIC]